In a moment like that one, I find myself afterwards thinking,...
..."I should've said something."
When I was younger, when I was only 14,...
...I was told by a drama teacher that I might do okay...
...if I was happy to settle for the fat girl parts.
Look at me now.
And so, what I feel like saying in those moments is any young woman...
...who has ever been put down by a teacher or a friend or even a parent,...
...just don't listen to any of it because that's what I did.
I didn't listen and I kept on going and I overcame all of my fears...
...and I got over a lot of insecurity.
And just keep doing it and keep believing in yourself.
That's what I felt like I really had to dig deep and do.
And so, I would dedicate it to all those young women who doubt themselves...
...because you shouldn't be doubting.
You should just be going for it.